Harry Potter is still pervasive in our
culture that yeah I know stuff about
Harry Potter it's impossible not to so
it's kind of a little bit exciting to
kind of see what all the fuss is about
I enjoy the theme of wizards and like
magic and everything like that but like
I can't commit myself to sitting and
reading a book I have seen some of the
movies I really can't follow what's
happening most of the time because
there's so many freaking characters I'm
not really really excited because I'm
actually gonna give it a chance if the
writing is good then I'll like it if the
writing is kind of boring and then I
probably won't I'm really specific about
what I read all right got the book I'm
gonna read it so read the first two
chapters of the book very easy to read
very fun man those those Dursleys are
real bad huh not to get like all
emotional but I feel like everyone can
relate to being like the black sheep and
the family or just like not having like
friends or not feeling close to like
anyone around them and so I don't know I
feel bad for Harry in a way that I never
did in the movies I started at work on
page five but I'm gonna I'm gonna finish
it let me get this straight
so Harry Potter gets detention his
detention is to go into the forbidden
woods and find a guide unicorn that's
not a punishment whoever sent those
letters to Harry was mad petty they were
like oh you're not gonna read that one
letter I sign you okay imma send you
another one oh you're not gonna read
that one
okay i'ma send you one hundred I just
finished reading chapter eleven which
has been one of my favorite chapters the
Quidditch game even though I would
prefer to see it in the movie it's still
pretty fun to kind of get the small
little details that they talk about why
are they so mean to Hermione also why
does Harry Potter get special treatment
why does he get a broom nobody else got
a broom I'd be pissed too
that's not fair every single part about
Harry's family makes me so sad I'm at
the part where he's like in front of the
mirror and he's like you just can't stop
looking at his family and I'm just like
it's just crazy that this kid isn't more
like up to be perfectly honest there's
so
words that are like British English and
Spanish is my first language so just
reading an English book first of all
it's a little bit of a challenge not too
much but then having words that are just
strictly like used by like British
people it's like another challenge one
thing that really sucks about reading
this book now is that everyone has
already read it I'm reading more and I'm
getting through more of it and getting
excited about more of it and there's no
one to share that excitement with me
everyone's already seen it so I'm just
kind of on my own here overall I think
the book was great I really do it was
fine it was like a good introduction to
the story I think that I would probably
enjoy it if like when the kids are
slightly older just cuz it felt very
much like for children all of these what
300 pages were just kind of like
building up the characters and like
letting you know them not really much of
a story happening on this book there's
just some plot holes some weird stuff I
feel like Harry Potter is a little bit
too privileged he's always just like
everyone's like sorry only for Harry
Potter or not for anyone else it's like
come on I'd be pissed off if I was one
of the kids there it's never too late to
start reading something even if it was
popular in the past you know I
definitely wish that I had read it when
I was younger because I think I would
have been able to relate to other people
more I have come to the conclusion the
Malfoy is a little